bonjour à tous je m'appelle Camille je
vais pas être plaisir aujourd'hui je
suis la seule fille donc je me suis dit
que j'allais donner le temps
et je commence par un visuel de planète
qui brûle
vous inquiétez pas tout va bien on va y
arriver
en fait j'ai mis visuelle parce qu'il y
a quelques années j'ai une grande prise
de conscience
en gros je me suis rendu compte qu'on
avait tous mourir
puis sérieusement j'ai pris tous les
chiffres en pleine gueule du
réchauffement climatique c'est un les 10
milliards d'habitants en 2050 les
milliers d'hectares de forêts dévastées
mais a priori tous ces chiffres vous les
connaissez et tu as de la planète vous
le connaissez
juste à m'enlever si je dis que en ce
moment la planète c'est pas top top
est-ce qu'il y en a qui sont surpris
es on est d'accord en tout cas moi j'ai
vraiment eu un moment clé où j'ai eu
cette prise de conscience et où j'ai
tout pris en pleine face
et mon premier réflexe du coup ça a été
de dire stop ok on arrête tout on
recommence changement radical de mes
habitudes je serai végane ou je ne serai
pas
et ce changement radical de mes
habitudes était basé sur une chose ma
volonté
de manière un peu sacrificielle
et du coup les gens autour de moi je les
comprenais pas forcément quand il
changeait pas j'avais envie de les
secouer je me disais que il s'en foutait
probablement
en fait je faisais preuve d'intolérance
je me rendais pas forcément compte
et rapidement je me suis rendue compte
que cette stratégie là elle menait à une
impasse pour moi pour les autres c'était
pas forcément durable est-ce que vous
avez pas forcément réalisé
c'est que la volonté
c'est une ressource finie
c'est pas que les gens s'en foutaient
c'est pas qu'ils avaient pas conscience
de ce qui se passait c'est pas qu'ils
étaient pas à l'armée c'est juste que
nos vies elles sont déjà trop
compliquées
nos journées sont déjà elles juste déjà
tellement notre volonté
que
on peut pas rajouter une couche en plus
de sacrifice en gros à la fin de la
journée je sais pas vous mais moi en
tout cas
je préfère me poser sur mon canapé avec
un bon Netflix
un peu comme elle
plutôt que vous me rappeler à chaque
fois à quel point la planète va mal et à
quel point c'est de ma faute
donc ok ça c'est une impasse il faut
changer de paradigme
et à ce moment là je me pose la question
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
différemment et il y a quelque chose qui
commence à frémir
c'est le moment plus ou moins ou le
documentaire demain comment ça faire du
bruit encore une fois à m'enlever qui a
déjà vu ce documentaire
ok vous êtes déjà c'est plus passionné
et ce documentaire c'est un documentaire
mais c'est aussi un récit qui met en
avant les histoires de gens qui essaient
de faire bouger les lignes à leur niveau
en partant au départ de leur propre
commune et de leur propre force
et qui concrètement arrive avec des
solutions
de manière plutôt joyeuse
ce documentaire illustre une fable la
fable du Colibri qui a été beaucoup
popularisée par le philosophe Pierre
Rabhi que vous connaissez peut-être
pour ceux qui la connaissent pas un jour
un terrible feu éclate en forêt
et tous les animaux constatent ce
désastre complètement catastrophique
désarmée ils sont impuissants face à ça
et il y a juste un tout petit animal qui
bouge dans tous les sens
c'est lui c'est le colibri
et en fait il fait des allers-retours il
est 7 prendre des gouttes d'eau avec son
bec et d'éteindre le feu ce qui est
entre nous est un peu ridicule vu qu'il
est seul
et le lion lui dit mais pourquoi tu
t'épuises tu sais bien que tu vas pas
éteindre ce feu à toi tout seul
et le colibri répond
je sais
mais je fais ma part
et la conviction des Français
documentaire et que je défends aussi ici
c'est que faire sa part c'est déjà
beaucoup et si on est beaucoup à faire
notre part en fait ça fait un effet
boule de neige
qu'au départ il y a une personne puis
quelques-unes et on arrive à un moment à
une masse critique de personnes qui fait
basculer les choses dans l'autre sens
qui crée une nouvelle normalité la norme
c'est plus de rien faire c'est de faire
quelque chose
donc ça c'est mon moment Eurêka
je comprends un truc
ce qui me marque dans ce documentaire
c'est la joie
hyper étonnant pour un documentaire sur
le réchauffement climatique
ces gens ils se bougent de manière
joyeuse en partant voilà de leur propre
force de leurs inclinations naturelles
Cyril lion qui a réalisé ce film il dit
quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup il dit
faire ce qu'on aime
en rayonnant
puissant et utile
il dit aussi
chacun d'entre nous a un talent chacun
d'entre nous peut faire sa part il
suffit de trouver comment ça a l'air
simple comme ça vous savez pas
mais moi aussi je me suis posé la
question ok donc c'est quoi mon truc à
moi c'est quoi mon talent et comment
est-ce que je peux faire ma part
et ce qui a résonné à ce moment-là
c'est l'alimentation
comme vous pouvez le voir je suis très
gourmande j'adore manger
certains pourraient me qualifier de
foody je sais pas si ça se dit encore
mais bon en gros mes amis quand ils vont
dans une nouvelle endroit un nouveau
quartier une nouvelle ville souvent il
me demande les bonnes adresses les bons
restos je trouve que c'est un signal
assez fort
aussi
travailler avec le futur d'alimentation
avec des nouveaux ingrédients par
exemple c'est très très créatif et pour
moi la créativité c'est important et
enfin on a l'occasion de manger trois
quatre fois par jour plutôt 4 pour moi
et du coup on a l'occasion de voter pour
le monde qu'on veut trois quatre fois
par jour
super concrète
et ça je trouve ça vraiment magique
donc mon truc c'est l'alimentation et je
vous invite vous aussi à vous poser la
question de ce fameux truc qui est votre
parce que ce que je pense c'est que vous
serez toujours plus utile en faisant un
job qui vous plaît et qui va dans le bon
sens
plutôt qu'en faisant un job un peu
absurde et en militant une heure par
semaine à côté
il y a un très grand philosophe des
temps modernes que vous connaissez
peut-être qui dit
réussir sans faire le bien c'est perdre
vous l'avez reconnu j'ai entendu c'est
vrai ça
et c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à
créer
au départ il y a 6 ans alors que j'étais
étudiante donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait chez
funky
on démocratise des produits qui sont
avant tout très très gourmands
et on essaie d'en rendre de faire des
alternatives plus responsables à ce qui
existe mais il y a pour la santé
meilleure pour la planète on réinvente
des incontournables de la gourmandise du
petit déj à l'apéro
en passant par la pâte à tartiner donc
par exemple une pâte à tartiner ouf
c'est la première pâte à tartiner sans
huile de palme du tout elle est aussi
bio elle est fabriquée en France elle a
un cahier des charges hypra exigeant
mais elle est le plus accessible
possible puisqu'elle est en rayon dans
des anciennes classiques juste à côté de
la pâte à tartiner commence par un N
et qui a de l'huile de palme à
l'intérieur
donc on a un cage on a un cahier des
charges
ultra exigeant mais la porte d'entrée
pour le consommateur chez nous c'est le
plaisir c'est le fait qu'il a pas besoin
de le radicalement bousculer ses
habitudes
et que il peut juste se faire du bien de
manière très simple
et ça a fait boule de neige
au départ c'était soirée week-end dans
ma cuisine donc pendant mes études j'ai
rencontré mon associé Adrien un peu par
hasard et maintenant on a une équipe
super motivée comme Pellois
on est présent dans 2000 magasins en
France on a vendu plus de 2 millions de
produits depuis la création
et la vraie star c'est pas Adrien c'est
pas moi c'est pas l'équipe
c'est elle la pâte à tartiner ouf
donc on vend un pot par minute
donc je vous laisse faire le calcul là
depuis que ça commence
tous cheminement il m'a fait repenser ma
boîte à outils pour changer le monde
dans ma boîte à outils pour changer le
monde il y a donc le plaisir
on pense souvent que se faire plaisir
c'est forcément coupable il y a quelque
chose d'un peu vicieux à l'idée de se
faire plaisir
je suis pas d'accord
pour moi se faire plaisir c'est beaucoup
plus profond c'est beaucoup plus humain
c'est partir donc de ses propres forces
de ses inclinations naturelles
de ce qui nous rend humain c'est pas le
plaisir de la société de consommation
c'est pas cette pulsion
qu'on essaie tout le temps de satisfaire
et qui finalement est jamais satisfaite
c'est vraiment humain le plaisir
puis il y a autre chose dans ma boîte à
outils il y a la tolérance l'indulgence
je vous ai dit je faisais pas tellement
preuve d'indulgence au départ
mais j'ai réalisé que on fait chacun de
notre mieux en fonction de ce qu'on a
comme ressources internes comme externe
on est tous très loin d'être parfait on
est parfaitement imparfait
et un autre grand philosophe que j'aime
beaucoup un narwin Orelsan d'ailleurs
qui dit dans une interview récente que
j'écoutais
tu ne peux donner qu'est-ce que tu as
et je suis d'accord parce que il faut
être rempli pour donner
donc le jugement l'intolérance on les
prend et on les sort direct de sa boîte
à outils
aujourd'hui je suis face à vous vous
êtes étudiant vous avez la vie devant
vous comme moi il y a 6 ans
vous avez chacun vos forces et vos
faiblesses ce que vous aimez ce que vous
aimez moins
et vous êtes tous des moteurs potentiels
de changement
donc je vais finir par juste une
question de en fait
qu'est-ce que vous aimez
et comment est-ce que vous allez changer
de monde
merci beaucoup